what's my hair install um like the top
of a radish hi guys my name is Chris ah
but you don't know now you know your
life is different now I'm out of breath
okay already done some Halloween costume
DIY it's on this channel for the
Halloween season of 2016 but that's not
going to stop me from continuing to do
that because I enjoy it very much I
think one of the most popular costumes
this Halloween is going to be snapchat
filters butterfly crown with the light
beautiful face thing that happens I
still don't understand how that filter
works what it does exactly but somehow
it just makes you look like so I tried
it to yourself and I don't I don't know
I've been feeling a lot of people are
going to be using the beautiful filters
that snapchat has to offer as their
Halloween costume but not grace Helbig
soon as I start feeling confident in
myself I just run run into the wall so
today I'm making a video showing you
three different DIY snapchat filter
costumes using the more perverted less
popular snapchat filters sunlights a
couple these turned out decent one of
these turned out real you tell me which
one you think that is enjoy so for this
first snapchat Halloween costume DIY I'm
taking this headpiece to a DI wide bear
costume so I could be the bear from
revenant for an Oscars party and I'm
cutting out a piece that looks like a
mustache
you can totally buy yourself a fake
mustache but if you have the opportunity
to upcycle a below-average revenant [ __ ]
you phone anyway just make the mustache
for the next accessory for this costume
I up cycled a familiar prop from a
recent Halloween DIY costume video that
you should watch I make a bunch of
costumes out of a sheet anyway I took
this piece of cardboard and I cut it
into a shape this is the shape then I
took some mounting tape tape that's used
to mount things to the wall and I put it
on the back of my upcycle fake mustache
so I could stick it to my face there are
obviously very easier ways to do this
but this is what I had
and I use some aviator sunglasses that I
happen to have in my house along with
this hat that I ordered off of Amazon
Prime now and then I immediately
realized that I put all this on too soon
because there's another prop that I
should have made before I did this so I
took some cardboard and I cut it into
the shape of a pine tree and I colored
it green with a sharpie and then I used
some metal wire ish stuff that I got
from Michael's to fasten it to the top
of the Hat
I'm sure you know what this filter is by
now it is not intentionally perfect but
I perceive it as pervy truck driver
that's definitely irresponsible because
at some point they run over something in
the road nail bit for the next snapchat
Halloween custom DIY I had to order
pacifiers off of Amazon which made me
feel like a full-fledged pervert which
is appropriate since these are the more
perverted filters yeah big-time pervert
but the pacifier didn't come in the
exact color that the filter I was
recreating was in so I took some
sharpies and I colored it in which you
know when you spend more than five
minutes char peeing a pacifier you'll
really evaluate your life a bit then I
went onto the Hat portion of this filter
if you can find a purple beanie that's
perfect but I could not find one so I
took this grey beanie that I bought of
Amazon and I took this purple foam paper
that I had and I traced it and glued it
on to the beanie and again there are
much better smarter faster stronger ways
to do this but I decided on this way and
this is what happened then I cut out two
tiny ear shaped pieces and hot glued
them on I don't know what I mean they're
like stunted bunny ears
I guess we're like really fat thumbs and
glued them onto the top of the beanie
then I use some sharpies and some paint
markers and I tried to recreate the
design that's on the beanie that's on
this snapchat filter as best I could
and it is you know I give myself a solid
70% then I use a mixture of pink and red
facepaint to give myself some flushed
ass cheeks then I put my hat on realized
it was way bigger than I wanted it to be
put my pacifier in and voila you got
pervert adult baby character thing
why did snapchat make this filter I
don't know but I just like it so here is
me celebrating it
this last snapchat filter DIY Halloween
costume was a lofty goal all you need
for it is makeup basically I tried to
draw bigger slightly slanted versions of
my own eyeballs on my eyelids and then
tried to use makeup to make my mouth
smaller and grumpier than it was so I
could recreate one of my all-time
favorite snapchat filters but let's be
honest I am no candy Johnson that was
going for that upside down mouth
snapchat filter and look I'm with you
guys
this one did not work out but I have
dedicated to figuring this out I'm gonna
keep trying actually well I lied I just
straight-up lied I'm not gonna keep
trying this why would I do this why
would I whip me so long to make this
piece of Shh
there you go there are three DIY
snapchat filter Halloween costumes using
the pervy unpopular filters I hope you
enjoyed this if you did don't forget to
like this video by giving it a thumbs up
and subscribing to my youtube channel by
clicking a button right here if you're
on a desktop laptop if you are a top
other than that I don't know come